오늘도 증시가 너무 좋습니다.
증시 3대 지수 모두 상승하고 있고
6가 하락하고 있는 이런 대폭등의 분위기에서
그래도 함정이 두 가지 정도 있는 것 같아서
그것도 한번 얘기를 해보겠습니다.
나스닥은 1.88% S&P500
1.12% 다우지수 0.63% 상승하는
정말 신나는 장이고요.
나스닥이 무려 10일 연속 상승하고 있고
S&P500 같은 경우는 전쟁 때 있었던 손실을 모두 만회했습니다.
연초 대비 YTD로 보면 결국에는 매우 3, 4월에 힘들었으나
모든 걸 다 만회했다 이렇게 볼 수가 있고요.
코스피 같은 경우도 한번 보면
코스피는 연초에 워낙 많이 올랐으니까
아직 전고점을 탈환하지는 못했지만
그래도 이제 얼핏 전고점 근처까지는 왔습니다.
6천 언저리까지 왔고요.
그리고 월요일에
연휴가격 다 6% 하락을 많이 해가지고
이쯤 되니까 지정학 위기에 대해서 증시 충격은
대부분의 경우에 단기적이라고 얘기했던
캔버지가 생각이 나서 한번 사진을 가지고 와봤고요.
캠피셔에게 제가 영상으로도 말씀드렸지만
계속 크게 방향성이 바뀐 게 없습니다.
그래서 특별히 더 말씀드릴 건 없는 것 같고
어쨌든 지금까지 모습으로만 보면
캠피셔가 꾸준히 얘기했던 증시 충격은 단기적이다라는 얘기
계속 유효화하지 않았나 이런 생각이 들고요.
그래서 지금까지 모습으로만 보면 캠피셔가 꾸준히 얘기했던 증시 충격은 단기적이다라는 얘기 계속 유효화하지 않았나 이런 생각이 들고요.
주가 상승의 이유를 좀 보면
전쟁이 확전보다는 휴전이 연장되거나
혹은 협상이 되는 그런 분위기로 가고 있는 게
가장 주가 상승의 큰 이유인 것 같고요.
두 번째는 오늘 이제 PPI라는 지표가 발표가 됐는데
이게 좀 예상보다 낮게 나왔어요.
그래서 이런 것들 물가 관련된 지표가 낮게 나온 거에 대해서
시장이 좀 더 긍정적으로 해석을 했다.
이렇게 볼 수가 있습니다.
그렇지만 둘 다 함정이 좀 있어요.
그래서 이 함정 얘기도 좀 해볼 거고요.
자 일단 전쟁 관련된 이야기부터
좀 해보겠습니다.
2월 28일에 전쟁이 시작이 됐죠.
그리고 4월 7일에
뭐 중간에 일들은 많았는데
일단 휴전을 합의를 했습니다.
그때부터 분위기가 완전히 바뀌었죠.
이 사이까지는 사실 엄청 힘들었는데
미국과 이란이 휴전에 합의를 하면서
시장의 분위기가 이때부터 완전 대폭등 분위기로
바뀌었다라고 볼 수가 있습니다.
곧 휴전 기한이 만료가 되긴 해요.
4월 21일에 협상 기한이 휴전 기한이 만료가 되기 때문에
이때까지가 이제 또 근처가
가면 또 어떤 일들이 일어날지 모르겠는데
어쨌든 지금까지는 분위기가 좋다.
이렇게 볼 수가 있겠고요.
다만 이제 지난 주말에
파키스탄에서 1차 협상을 했는데
결렬이 됐습니다.
그리고 현재 분위기는 2차 협상을
어디서 할지 날짜와 장소를
조율 중이다라는 얘기가 있고요.
파키스탄에서 할 수도 있을 것 같고
뭐 다른 곳에서도 할 수가 있을 것 같은데
이건 좀 분위기를 봐야 될 것 같습니다.
트럼프의 말에 따르면
이틀 내로 협상이 재개가 가능하다.
이런 얘기를 하고 있습니다.
협상의 핵심 쟁점은 핵 프로그램이죠.
그래서 이거에 대해서 의견이 서로 갈리고 있는데
미국 같은 경우는
20년간 핵과 관련된 것들 다 하지 마라.
이렇게 얘기를 했고
그래도 알려진 바에 따르면
이란이 역제한을 했다라고 해요.
20년은 아니고 5년간 우리가 관련된 걸 중단을 하겠다.
이런 뉴스들이 나오면서
오히려 이란의 역제한 뉴스가 나오면서
사실 상당히 좀 긍정적으로 분위기가 바뀌었어요.
왜냐하면 어쨌든 협상의 여지가 있는 것 같잖아.
야 5년간 중단을 해.
5년간 할게.
라는 것 자체가
어쨌든 협상할 의지가 있음을 보여준 거기 때문에
이런 이란의 역제한 뉴스에 대해서도
시장이 상당히 긍정적으로 반응을 했습니다.
다만 여기서 금쪽이 이스라엘이 한마디를 하죠.
농축 우라늄 완전 제거라는 게 전제 조건이다.
이란 이스라엘은 훨씬 더 뭔가 빡세게 가려고 하는
여전히 그런 의도를 보여주고 있죠.
그리고 이스라엘의 정보국 같은 거죠.
국정원 같은 모사드의 수장은
우리의 임무가 아직 완료되지 않습니다.
완료되지 않았다라는 얘기를 하고 있고요.
그래서 이란의 정권이 계속 협상의 암초 같은 역할을
협상을 막고 있는 역할을 이스라엘이 하고 있지 않나
이런 생각을 좀 해보고요.
그 외에도 이스라엘과 레바논도 대화를 하고 있습니다.
안 그래도 이스라엘이 레바논을 공격하면서
초반의 분위기, 특히 협상 극초반의 분위기를
정말 안 좋게 끌고 갔었는데
어쨌든 이 레바논이라는 나라에
헤즈볼라라는 무장단체, 정당이라고 볼 수도 있고
어쨌든 헤즈볼라라는 무장단체는
헤즈볼라라는 조직이 있기 때문에
그거에 대해서 그리고 그 헤즈볼라라는 조직 자체가
이란과 매우 긴밀하기 때문에
요거가 싫어서 이스라엘이 레바논을 공격한 거죠.
그래서 이스라엘의 목표는
헤즈볼라 무장을 해제해달라고 하는 건데
레바논 입장에서는 사실 레바논 정부보다
헤즈볼라가 힘이 더 센데 어떻게 레바논 정부가
헤즈볼라를 붙잡겠습니까? 무장해제하겠습니까?
그러니까 일단은 휴전부터 하자라는 그런 상황이고
어쨌든 계속 요게 이슈가 있는데
이 레바논 정부와 이스라엘이
대화를 하기 시작한 거는 팩트다 이렇게 볼 수가 있겠습니다.
자 이런 상황 속에서 미국이 절묘한
정말 트럼프가 절묘한 안을 들고 왔죠.
이란이 호르무지를 봉쇄면 나도 호르무지를 봉쇄할 거다.
어떤 배도 이란의 항구에서 출발해서 지나갈 수가 없다.
역으로 미국이 호르무지를 봉쇄해버렸어요.
그러면서 미국이 첫 24시간 동안
이란 봉쇄를 통과한 선박이 없다고 밝혔습니다.
그러니까 너희만 바라봐요.
바다를 봉쇄할 수 있는 게 아니라
우리도 바다를 봉쇄할 수 있다라는 게
현재 미국의 작전이고
처음에 이걸 보고 증시도 그렇고
제 주변 사람들도
야 이거 미국까지 이러면 더 큰일 나는 거 아니야
라고 생각을 했지만
또 가만히 생각해 보니까
이게 말이 되는 작전이긴 한 것 같아요.
무슨 얘기냐면
미국도 이 호르무즈 그리고 이란을 아예
해안선 이란의 바다를 막아버리면
이란에 대한 압박이 상당하지 않겠습니까?
왜냐하면
이란은
그 돈줄은
유조선을 통해서 이란에서 나가는
그 많은 배들일 텐데
수많은 유조선으로부터 만들어지는
그런 돈으로 이란이 버티고 있는 건데
이렇게 이란에서 어떤 배도 수출을 할 수 없게
바다를 통해서 수출을 할 수 없게 만들면
상당히 이란도 곤란해지는 거죠.
왜냐하면 전쟁 물자를 대야 되고
이란 이미 경제가 파탄한 상황에서
할 수 있는 게 아무것도 없다면
이란에게 상당히 경제적으로 충격이 돼서
이란을 단기적으로 훨씬 더 압박할 수 있는
그런 상황이 되는 것 같고
또 중국도 영향을 받죠.
물론 중국이 이란에 대한 의존도가
엄청 높은 건 아니긴 합니다.
제가 알기로는 에너지의 한 10% 정도를
이란에게 의존하고 있지만
어쨌든 중국도 상당히 또 압박을 받을 거고
중국이 또 이란을 압박해 줄 수도 있는 거기 때문에
처음에는 이걸 왜 이렇게 하나 싶었던 작전이
생각해 보니까
이란을 상당히 압박할 수가 있을 것 같아요.
어쨌든 이란이 육상을 통해서
혹은 다른 루트를 통해서 한다고 해도
이 원유라는 게
아시겠지만 루트를 그렇게 그냥 바꾸는 게
말처럼 쉽지가 않거든요.
이미 만들어 놓은 인프라들이 많기 때문에
기존에 만들어 놓은 이 루트를 따라갈 수밖에 없는데
그렇기 때문에 이란이 상당히 경제적으로
곤란한 상황에 떨어진 것 같다.
이런 생각이 들고
제가 이런 느낌을 받는 거는
어쨌든 이렇게 미국이 이란의 바다를 봉쇄한 이후부터
이란의 태도가 좀 더 유하게 바뀐 느낌이 있어요.
그런 거를 느낍니다.
이런 어떤 이란의 역제안에서
다만 단서를 좀 달고 싶습니다.
함정이 좀 있다라고 생각을 하는 게
정치인들 간의 협상이기 때문에
이런 협상들 어떤 방향으로 칠지
정말 알 수가 없는 것 같아요.
그래서 물론 저는 여전히 저한테 물어보신다면
저는 긍정적이다 라고 말씀을 드리겠지만
이런 함정이 있다라는 말씀 하나 드리고 싶고
그리고 또 물가지표가 나왔죠.
여기서 보통 제가 물가지표 말씀드리면
CPI를 말씀드리는데
여기서는 PPI라는 생산자 입장에서의
물가지수를 말씀드리는 건데
PPI 지표가 전년 대비해서 원래 4.6% 상승하셨는데
4.6% 상승할 거라고 생각했는데
4.0% 상승하는 걸로 그쳤고
전 월 대비해서도 원래 1.1% 오를 거라고 생각했으나
0.5% 상승하는 걸로 그쳤습니다.
그래서 모든 어떤 지표들이 다 예상치를 대폭 하회했어요.
그래서 시장이 이걸 이거에 좀 환호를 했고
좀 뜯어보면 에너지가 매우 높게 올라갔는데
서비스랑 식품이 그래도 별로 안 올라가면서 상쇄를 했습니다.
그러다 보니까 시장이 긍정적인 뉴스를 줬죠.
원준이 굳이 긴축을 급하게 할 필요는 없구나
이런 시사점을 줬고요.
다만 함정도 좀 있습니다.
원래 물가 반영은 천천히 된다라는 거고
그래서 다음 달부터 PPI, CPI 본격적으로 반영이 되지 않겠느냐라는 얘기가 있고
또 설문조사, PPI도 설문조사 기반인데
이 측정하는 타이밍이 좀 잘못되지 않았느냐
가솔린 가격이 본격적으로 올라가기 이전에 측정을 하면서
그 설문조사를 잘못된 타이밍에 하지 않았느냐
그래서 헤드라인 수치가 낮게 나온 거다라는
얘기가 계속 있습니다.
그래서 타이밍적으로 이번 달에 넘어간 거지
4월 물가는 훨씬 더 안 좋을 가능성이 높다라는 그런 얘기
그런 의견들이 있고
이게 제가 또 보는 함정이라고 생각을 합니다.
자, 그리고 오늘 주요 미국의 은행들의 실적 발표가 있었는데
자, 이들의 기본적인 이야기가 좀 긍정적이었어요.
그래서 이란 전쟁에도 불구하고 미국 경제가 꽤 견고하다
이런 얘기를 했습니다.
그래서 이런 것도 아마 시장에서
긍정적으로 받아들여졌을 것 같고
또 그 외에 제가 틈날 때마다 조금씩 말씀을 드리는데
AI 관련된 얘기가 요즘에 또 많아요.
왜냐면 오픈클로와 클로드 코드를 클로드 이슈로
클로드의 성능이 너무 좋다라는 얘기들이 나오면서
지금 AI 수요가 엄청나다라는 얘기가
뭐 여러 가지 간접적인 지표에서도 나오고 있고
월스트리트 저널에서도 AI 수요가 엄청나다라는 기사를 또 냈습니다.
그러면서 AI 쪽이 정말 미쳐날뛰고 있는 그런 상황이고요.
뭐 그러다 보니까
주요 AI 관련된 주식들
한국에서는 뭐 하이닉스 같은 주식들
혹은 미국에서는 뭐 블룸에너지 뭐 이런 회사들
뭐 다 뭐 광통신 회사들
요즘에 또 낸드 회사들도 난리고
그래서 지금 AI 관련된 주요 주식들이 다
어 전고점 근처까지 올라왔다
요런 얘기를 드립니다.
자 그리고 또 뭐 이런 기사도 조선비지에서 나오더라고요.
이제는 정액제
어 한 달 구독하면 무제한 쓸 수 있는 AI 시대가 끝나고
이제는 쓰는 만큼 돈을 내야 되는
그런 걸로 바뀌는 거 아니냐
요런 얘기죠.
얘기가 많습니다.
그래서 조선비지에 이런 기사가 나서
한번 얘기를 좀 해 봤고요.
그리고 뭐 클로드 미소스라는 새로운 또 모델이 나오는데
엄청난 모델이다라는 얘기가 많은데
요건 좀 좀 더 뭔가 잡히는 얘기가 있으면 얘기를 해 보도록 하고요.
자 이미 증시 주가 많이 회복하기도 했지만
저는 여전히 이 지정학적 위기가
긍정적으로 흘러갈 가능성이 높다라고 생각을 합니다.
물론 이미 많이 회복한 상태긴 하지만
뭐 아시겠지만
저는 초반부터 여전히 긍정적으로 어..
증시가..
어..
이 문제를 극복해낼 가능성이 높다라고 말씀을 드리긴 했었어요.
이 문제가 터진 극초기부터
다만 제가 생각한 것보다 조금 더 빨리 치고 올라온 거 같고
이게 다시 또 전 고점을 향해 도전하는
마치 이 이벤트가 일어나기 전처럼
이렇게 빨리 주가가 회복될 거라고 생각은 못 했는데
어쨌든 뭐 이런 모습을 보이고 있고
그러다 보니까 약간의 불안함이 존재하는 건 사실입니다.
시장에 대한 걱정이 있으신 분들은 오히려 이럴 때
뭐 레버리지를 줄인다거나
아니면 약간의 현금을 만들어 놓는 게
오히려 약간은 도망갈 구석도
숨 쉴 구멍도 만들어 놓는 게 좋지 않나
뭐 이런 생각도 저는 좀 들더라고요.
그래서 왜냐면 증시
S&P 기준으로는 연초 대비랑 똑같은데
모든 게 완전히 회복된 건 아니잖아.
모든 이슈가 다 끝난 건 아니니까
또 지정학적으로 안 좋은 이슈가 있을 수도 있으니까
뭐 약간 현금을 오히려 올타임 할 때
약간의 현금을 조금씩 가져가는 것도
심리적인 어떤 쿠션을 만드는 좋은 방법이지 않을까
뭐 이런 생각이 있어서
오히려 증시가 좋을 때
약간은 조심하자 이런 말씀을 드리는 게
맞지 않나
오히려 힘들 때 야 지금이 기회야
이렇게 가는 게 맞고
좋을 때 조금 조심하자
이런 얘기를 하는 게 맞지 않나
이런 생각이 들어서
저는 투자와 관련된 블로그
그리고 인스타그램 하고 있으니까
궁금하신 분들은 고정 댓글 설명란 참고 부탁드립니다.
감사합니다.